hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of Marlena masters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow a business is some
model the strategies of people who have
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're gonna look at how a young
woman who was born into a slave family
went from that to becoming the first
self-made millionaire in America this is
a story of madam CJ Walker in the top
three lessons you can learn from her
success madam CJ Walker was born Sarah
Breedlove in delta Louisiana born into a
slave family Walker rose from her humble
beginnings to establish herself as the
first self-made woman millionaire in
America after experiencing a personal
setback Walker turned her fate around
and used that setback to create a
fortune at a time when most African
Americans were struggling to find work
Walker pioneered her wait at the top of
the hair care and cosmetics industries
walk Wood faced a host of tragedies
throughout her life such as losing her
parents into Sarah young losing her
first husband marrying two more times
but none of these tragedies is what made
her look to start her own business in
1904 crisis would again strike walker's
life she'd been working so hard and
eating so poorly that she began losing
her hair she tried product after product
to help and try to save her hair but
nothing worked
later that year Walker attended a
seminar that would change the course of
her life I may could do something about
her problem Walker credits God with
having given her the special hair remedy
that would launch her business God
however could not do anything about the
fact that there was already another
entrepreneur selling similar products in
st. Louis not one in the face of
competition head-on Walker decided to
take her show on the road in 1913 Walker
bought a house in Harlem and decided to
make it her new company's headquarters
slowly the company continued to grow and
by 1917 annual conventions were being
held by Walker's agents trained new and
old
by the time Walker died in 1919 she was
51 years old and one of the richest
women in the country by believing in
herself and by moving forward from her
personal setbacks Madame CJ Walker was
able to go from being in a slave family
to becoming the first self-made
millionaire in America to help you
overcome your setbacks here are the top
three action items you can learn from
madam CJ Walker action item number one
don't let your situation be an excuse
for not starting it's easy to think of
reasons why you can't be successful you
don't have a lot of money your parents
weren't entrepreneurs nobody believes in
your ideas everyone tells you you're
crazy and the list goes on most of the
world's most famous successful
entrepreneurs came from absolutely
nothing they didn't have any resources
but they were resourceful and they
believed in themselves trust that what
you're doing is right and go after what
you want have confidence and believe
that you can do it
Walker was an ambitious entrepreneur and
once she got started that was it once
business started to boom Walker found it
impossible to give in to her husband's
demands that she settled he wanted her
to be happy with her business and was
opposed to any plans for growth
it was making $10 a day and he didn't
see much more potential for growth he
believed that taking such big risks and
expanding nationally would be an unwise
move however she was so driven that it
ruined her marriage and even this could
not stop her it was not until walk was
39 years old and she decided to go into
business for herself she had no formal
education no business experience and a
daughter to support but Walker decided
that this would be her second start in
life Walker decided that it is never too
late to chase her dreams and pursue
success according to Walker when we
began to make $10 a day
my ex-husband thought that was enough
thought I ought to be satisfied but I
was convinced that my hair preparation
would fill a long felt want and when we
found it impossible to agree due to the
narrowness of his vision I embarked on
business for myself
action on a number to act on crisis
don't accept it when faced with crisis
people either shrink down or they rise
up which one are you going to do a lot
of the world's greatest ideas came
because entrepreneurs were in a crisis
and had to find the solution if you can
solve a crisis for yourself chances are
there are many other people out there
who will gladly pay you to help them
solve it as well and you're on your way
to business success walk was 37 years
old when she found herself slowly losing
her hair she would wake up each morning
with new clumps of hair on her pillow
that had fallen out the night before she
didn't know what was causing it but
suspected a combination of poor diet and
stress it is now known to have been a
common problem among black women during
that time but while others might have
just disguised a problem with a wig or
hidden themselves away from the rest of
the world Walker decided to turn this
crisis into an opportunity walk was
always on the lookout for an opportunity
and by and large she took those
opportunities when she was in midst of a
difficult time in her life it was by
acting on crises instead of accepting
them that walk was able to turn a scarce
living into a success according the
Walker I was a woman who came from the
cotton fields of the south from there
was promoted to the washtub from the
Arras rota to the cook kitchen and from
there I promoted myself into the
business of manufacturing hair goods and
preparations I have built my own factory
on my own ground I got my start by
giving myself a start action item number
three make perseverance your motto one
trade successful entrepreneurs all have
in common is they don't quit they face
challenges and they persevere you might
have moments of weakness we think you're
never going to make it then you should
go get a job push through those moments
and keep going you're closer than you
think I need to keep taking consistent
action every day to move closer to your
goal Walker could not have gotten from
where she started to where she wound up
without a healthy dose of perseverance
being born as an african-american in the
19th century the odds were already
stacked against her it was a time when
few African Americans let alone women
running their own businesses and making
a success of it the majority had little
education and were either unemployed or
underemployed Walker however was
determined not to share that same fate
for the rest of her life by 1913 her
company had a sales force of over 20,000
people throughout not only the US but
also Central America and the Caribbean
her sales agents mostly black women went
from making $2.00 a week as domestic
workers to $25 a week selling Walker's
products to them she was a savior who
opened up a world of new opportunities
had Walker chose not to persevere she
would not have been the only one missing
out according to Walker
there is no royal flower-strewn path to
success and if there is I haven't found
it for everything I've accomplished in
my life has been because I've been
willing to work hard perseverance is my
motto so remember don't let your
situation be an excuse act on crisis
don't accept it and let perseverance be
your motto to finish up this video I
wanted to share my favorite true stories
about madam CJ Walker and some of her
best quotes
in 1917 Walker commissioned a 30 foreign
room mansion to be built for her in the
Hudson River it was her dream house so
then she had worked for years field to
afford but when Airy residents found out
who their new neighbor was going to be
they were less than happy one of the
race wrote one newspaper is invading the
domains of New York's aristocracy the
New York Times even wrote no woman of
her race could own such a place does she
really intend to live there this was
only some of the discrimination Walker
faced throat her life one little-known
story is about the time she went to see
a movie and was charged twice but white
people work being charged to see the
show she immediately hired an attorney
and sued the movie theater winning the
case she then went on to build her own
movie theater to support the black
residents of New York which became a
successful theatre and did not
discriminate against white residents
anyone could come to the shows and
everyone paid the same ticket price
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling the masters if you
liked the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below I don't
so love to hear oh you have to think if
you want to leave a comment underneath
the video and see you at the next
episode
you